[Music]
as you see [__] Chris Brown no you
didn't see that clip
can we watch the clip
so he brings this girl up on stage I
don't know if this is something he does
every show or what but like he brings up
on stage sits he said it must be yeah
yeah but yeah it still felt like [__]
intrusive you know just even the first
part he brings up one stage sits her
down in the chair and he like does this
dance where he like you know he like
mounts her basically and like [__] her
like air [__] her
and that part was like Ugh [__] weird
and then she's like taking selfies and
[__] like that afterwards I'll just let
her I'll just let her play
yeah this is the angle so first of all
that was like wild right
but she doesn't look like she was into
that at all yeah she's clearly like on
her phone because she's uncomfortable
and he just
all right all right all right I'm not
even trying to dude I'm not even trying
to be contrarian here the Slick like the
slickness of that is hilarious what do
you mean like I'm not trying to be like
hey I you know
this is funny but that is funny
like go back go back look the trends how
quick that happened no no go back like
five seconds
[Laughter]
oh there's a someone screenshotted like
the picture like the picture of the
screen because you can see the backup
dancer and he's like
and afterwards they're all looking at
you like yo what the [__] I would feel
so weird if I if my job is to [__] the
air yeah in front of a random fan and
then my boss
takes property of said fan and just
Hucks it into the crowd I'm like
[Laughter]
I don't even have a concert a lot of
people still yeah it's really crazy that
people are just still pulling up dude
it's like the most uncancelable person
somehow yeah he's just like continuing
to prove himself as like a [__] yeah
he keeps doing it yeah
like
every every you know every artist you
get annually I think you get one Steve
Lacy moment yeah wait wait what did he
do he chucked that Fan's phone okay
I didn't see that I think every artist
is you know you get at least one of
those okay
what did the fan do
uh it's just phones oh no no I think
what it was is the fan it was like more
rude it was like they just threw a like
they just threw a camp like a disposable
camera on stage and he just chucked it
on the ground yeah yeah okay I think and
that's fine yeah that's fine I think I
think that's totally allowed yeah I
think when he smashed the phone he like
walked off stage for a second he came
back when he smashed the camera
I think the whole crowd in that moment
should have universally been like yeah
yeah yeah they also just gotten quiet
turned to her and been like you need to
leave yeah yeah yeah yeah
all 2 000 people should just ah
yeah we're with him yeah you gotta go
yeah what you did was messed up the
whole crowd just like like Moses like
they just all split they just create an
empty way for her and they just point
yeah yeah
I mean I feel like
yeah for it's like twofold for him it's
like
it's not part of the show
yeah it's like I'm practicing my art in
front of you I'm performing this show
for you and it's like all you care about
is getting that like picture from like
they're the be real or whatever the [__]
yeah the whole but also as a fan it's
like that's part of the reason why you
go to the shows yeah pictures and videos
that you were there yes the whole moment
is very
by the way I'm saying this in in defense
of Steve Lacy
Chris Brown yeah this was really [__]
up no I was gonna say that Chris Brown
thing is is funny because
it's such a that's like a objectively
like dystopian thing
yeah like just someone on like their
handheld computer like
look at me you know like it's very weird
but also you just air [__] the [__] out
of this person
you know what what like what did you
want her reaction to be
you know I feel like yeah yeah I don't
know is this something he does every
show I'm wondering and the girls are
usually like oh my God like flattered by
it or something
because she's clearly afterwards like uh
that was [__] weird yeah I just was
on this guy's
Tick-Tock feed he's a guy like goes
around to people in SoHo in New York and
it's like what's your what do you do
what's your career right and he's got
this one video that has like a [__] ton
of views because it's Adam Sandler in
the thumbnail um and
he walks up to Adam Sandler he's like
Adam Sandler yo what do you do bro what
do you do and Adam Sandler's like what's
what's up buddy just like gives him a
pass like all right get your phone out
of my [__] face what's up buddy and
he's like uh I forget what he says but
he's like what do you do what's your
career or something like that an Adam
Sandler hits the guy's phone
and all the comments are like wow Adam
Sandler didn't pass the vibe check Adam
Sandler didn't pass nah he did he
totally passed away what do you mean
yeah yeah he probably gets that [__]
constantly and this guy walks up to him
in the street first of all like
approaches him like quickly yeah jams
his phone in his face and asks him some
stupid question what do you think his
reaction's gonna be yeah yeah
these are the same people that comment
on another video like if someone did
that [__] to me I'd knock him the [__]
out yeah yeah it's like okay dude yeah
people just want to be upset
go search that guy on Tick Tock what do
you do for a living maybe just search
what do you do for a living guy
what do you do for a living
yo Rich the kid what are you doing
what do you do for a living no
excuse me
yo what do you do for a living
look for a good uh what do you do for a
living I'm a lawyer really yes you look
familiar yeah I play one on TV what do
you do for a living I'm a musician
really what kind of musician dude his
phone is right in their face
writing songs
what do you do for him
DJ on a record label excuse me what do
you do for a living I think I'm a new
life that's what's up
that's what's up
what do you do for a living nothing
nothing what do you do for a living
Lance what do you do for telling me come
on Lance
come on man you tell me what you do for
a living please
I hate it yeah
yeah
I think he's uh what's that famous
photographer
he would it's like the 70s or like 80s
or some [__] he just like walk up to
people and just like flash photo like in
the street right in their [__] face
is the modern random people yeah
and he like kind of
you know he
established some stuff for this like
photography style where it is like Photo
like his photography was just like
invasive as [__] and I think a lot of
the photos are people just kind of like
the hell
yeah and this is that yeah but I hate it
I hate it
I did not expect that reaction from
Adamson all right dude
what did you expect I mean some people
are nicer off the bat because they're
like but you can tell they're still kind
of like stop following them yeah get on
my face
it's so off-putting jamming your camera
in someone's face and it's recording
well saying stuff yeah Adam also came up
in like no matter who you are yeah yeah
Adam came up in like the aggressive
Paparazzi era yeah true yeah that's
still a thing but I feel like it was
when it that was like the only Outlet
yeah that dude was probably getting it
every day yeah
he's like I've he's like dude I [__]
punched a a 50 to 500 lens with my bare
knuckle yeah yeah yeah you know yeah
that [__] is that [__] is like punching
a thermos yeah I'll punch your stupid
little [__] piece of you know yeah
your your half inch thick cell phone
clean out of your pants yeah and Adam
Sandler plays basketball yeah true
he was asking for it
anyway sorry
yeah this is what have you like went up
to Chris Brown Yo Chris Brown what do
you do for a living Chris Brown was like
[Laughter]
oh
my God